HE THROWS AROUND THE OTHER
SIDE, BUT HE
VERY, VERY GOOD RETURN ON DRAFT
DAY.
HURRICANES NOW.
THAT IS SMITH WITH THE FORWARD.
COULD BE A TEAM, THEY COULD
SCORE OFF FACE-OFFS.
MIDDLE.
ONE ABSOLUTELY.
IT SOUNDED LIKE A FASTBALL.
AND A CLEAN FACE OFF WITH IS PR
WELL PLAYED.
GERMAN JORDAN STST SAVE, REBOUN
GREAT JOB DURING THE KICK AWAY.
TO PUSH HIS PLAYERS, AND YOU
CAN TELL THAT HE LOVES BEING A
COACH.
ELVIS, NOT ONE, BUT TWO.
HE'S GOT HIS SHOES ON. FOUND A
OF BAGS OF TRICKS, AND HE
ALMOST HAD THE
EYEBALL TO EYEBALL, THEY BEGIN
THE SECOND.
I LIKE HOW FRANCE
TEENAGER STILL HERE.
NJORKSTRAND, SHOTS.IN FRONT.
A NICE BLOCKER !
CHINAKHOV SCORES!
CAROLINA NEEDS WHEN HERE.THEIR
WATCH OUT.
YEGOR CHINAKHOV, SECOND  THE LI
PUT AWAY WITH A 4-0 LEAD AND BI.